نمت مثل الحشيش وكما تعلم ،
كنا دائمًا في كوبرتينو ومن
الواضح أننا بحاجة إلى بناء حرم جامعي جديد
وما فعلناه هو أننا اشترينا هذه
الأرض هنا في الحرم الجامعي الذي نرغب في
بنائه  هناك مبنى واحد
يتسع لـ 12000 شخص ، إنه
يشبه إلى حد ما سفينة فضاء هبطت ، إنه يحتوي على هذا
الفناء الرائع في المنتصف ، إنه عبارة عن
دائرة ومنحنيات على طول الطريق ،
هل تعلم أنك إذا كنت تبني أشياء ،
فهذه ليست أرخص طريقة لبناء
شيء ما  لا توجد
قطعة زجاجية مستقيمة في هذا المبنى ،
بارتفاع أربعة طوابق للمبنى ، نريد أن نجعل 80٪
منه أفقيًا ، مما يجعل مركز الطاقة
مصدر الطاقة الأساسي لدينا واستخدام
الشبكة كنسخة احتياطية لدينا لدينا
قاعة لأننا وضعناها
العروض التقديمية ومركز اللياقة
وبعض مرافق البحث والتطوير أعتقد أن لدينا فرصة
لبناء أفضل
مبنى مكاتب في العالم